The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
We keep on talking
about principal component
analysis, which we essentially
introduced as a way to
work with a bunch of data.
So the data that's given to
us when we want to do PCA
is a bunch of vectors X1 to Xn.
So they are random vectors.
in Rd.
And what we mentioned
is that we're
going to be using linear
algebra-- in particular,
the spectral theorem-- that
guarantees to us that if I look
at the convenience
matrix of this guy,
or its empirical
covariance matrix,
since they're
symmetric real matrices
and they are positive
semidefinite,
there exists a diagonalization
into non-negative eigenvalues.
And so here, those
things live in Rd,
so it's a really large space.
And what we want to
do is to map it down
into a space that
we can visualize,
hopefully a space
of size 2 or 3.
Or if not, then we're just going
to take more and start looking
at subspaces altogether.
So think of the case where d
is large but not larger than n.
So let's say, you have a
large number of points.
The question is, is it possible
to project those things onto
a lower dimensional
space, d prime,
which is much less than d-- so
think of d prime equals, say,
2 or 3--
and so that you keep
as much information
about the cloud of points
that you had originally.
So again, the example
that we could have
is that X1 to Xn for, say,
Xi for patient i's recording
a bunch of body measurements
and maybe blood pressure,
some symptoms, et cetera.
And then we have a
cloud of n patients.
And we're trying to
visualize maybe to see if--
If I could see, for
example, that there's
two groups of
patients, maybe I would
know that I have two
groups of different disease
or maybe two groups
of different patients
that respond differently
to a particular disease
or drug et cetera.
So visualizing is
going to give us
quite a bit of insight about
what the spatial arrangement
of those vectors are.
And so PCA says, well, here,
of course, in this question,
one thing that's not defined
is what is information.
And we said that
one thing we might
want to do when we project
is that points do not
collide with each other.
And so that means we're
trying to find directions,
where after I project, the
points are still pretty spread
out.
And so I can see
what's going on.
And PCA says-- OK,
so there's many ways
to answer this question.
And PCA says, let's just
find a subspace of dimension
d prime that keeps as much
covariance structure as
possible.
And the reason is
that those directions
are the ones that maximize
the variance, which
is a proxy for the spread.
There's many, many
ways to do this.
There's actually a
Google video that
was released maybe last week
about the data visualization
team of Google that shows
you something called
t-SNE, which is
essentially something
that tries to do that.
It takes points in
very high dimensions
and tries to map them
in lower dimensions,
so that you can
actually visualize them.
And t-SNE is some
alternative to PCA
that gives an other definition
for the word information.
I'll talk about this towards
the end, how you can actually
somewhat automatically
extend everything
we've said for PCA to an
infinite family of procedures.
So how do we do this?
Well, the way we do
this is as follows.
So remember, given
those guys, we
can form something which is
called S, which is the sample,
or the empirical
covariance matrix.
And since from
couple of slides ago,
we know that S has a
eigenvalue decomposition,
S is equal to PDP transpose,
where P is orthogonal.
So that's where we use our
linear algebra results.
So that means that P transpose P
is equal to PP transpose, which
is the identity.
So remember, S is
a d by d matrix.
And so P is also d by d.
And d is diagonal.
And I'm actually going to take,
without loss of generality,
I'm going to assume that d--
so it's going to be
diagonal-- and I'm
going to have something
that looks like lambda 1
to lambda d.
Those are called the
eigenvalues of S.
What we know is that lambda
j's are non-negative.
And actually, what I'm
going to assume without loss
of generalities is lambda 1
is larger than lambda 2, which
is larger than lambda d.
Because in particular,
this decomposition--
the spectrum decomposition--
is not entirely unique.
I could permute
the columns of P,
and I would still have
an orthogonal matrix.
And to balance that,
I would also have
to permute the entries of d.
So there's as many
decompositions
as there are permutations.
So there's actually quite a bit.
But the bag of
eigenvalues is unique.
The set of
The ordering is
certainly not unique.
So here, I'm just
going to pick--
I'm going to nail down one
particular permutation--
actually, maybe two in
case I have equalities.
But let's say, I pick
one that satisfies this.
And the reason why I do this
is really not very important.
It's just to say,
I'm going to want
to talk about the largest
of those eigenvalues.
So this is just
going to be easier
for me to say that
this one is lambda 1,
rather than say it's lambda 7.
So this is just to say that
the largest eigenvalue of S
is lambda 1.
If I didn't do that, I would
just call it maybe lambda max,
and you would just know
which one I'm talking about.
So what's happening now
is that if I look at d,
then it turns out
that if I start--
so if I do P transpose Xi, I am
actually projecting my Xi's--
I'm basically changing
the basis for my Xi's.
And now, D is the
empirical covariance matrix
of those guys.
So let's check that.
So what it means is
that if I look at--
so what I claim is
that P transpose Xi--
that's a new vector, let's
call it Yi, it's also in Rd--
and what I claim is that the
covariance matrix of this guy
is actually now this
diagonal matrix, which
means in particular that
if they were Gaussian, then
they would be independent.
But I also know now that
there's no correlation
across coordinates of Yi.
So to prove this, let me assume
that X bar is equal to 0.
And the reason why I do
this is because it's just
annoying to carry out all
this censuring constantly
and I talk about S. So
when X bar is equal to 0,
that implies that S
has a very simple form.
It's of the form
sum from i equal 1
to n of Xi Xi transpose.
So that's my S.
But what I want is the S of Y--
So OK, that implies
also that P times X
bar, which is equal to P times
X bar is also equal to 0.
So that means that Y bar--
Y has mean 0, if this is 0.
So if I look at the sample
covariance matrix of Y,
it's just going to
be something that
looks like the sum of the
outer products or the Yi Yi
transpose.
And again, the reason why
I make this assumption
is so that I don't have to write
minus X bar X bar transpose.
But you can do it.
And it's going to
work exactly the same.
So now, I look at this S prime.
And so what is this S prime?
Well, I'm just going
to replace Yi with PXi.
So it's the sum from i equal
1 to n of PXi PXi transpose,
which is equal to the sum from--
sorry there's a 1/n.
So it's equal to 1/n
sum from i equal 1
to n of PXi Xi
transpose P transpose.
Agree?
I just said that the transpose
of AB is the transpose of B
times the transpose of A.
And so now, I can
push the sum in.
P does not depend on i.
So this thing here is
equal to PS P transpose,
because the sum of the Xi Xi
transpose divided by n is S.
But what is PS P transpose?
Well, we know that
S is equal to--
sorry that's P transpose.
So this was with a P transpose.
I'm sorry, I made an
important mistake here.
So Yi is P transpose Xi.
So this is P transpose
and P transpose
here, which means that
this is P transpose
and this is double transpose,
which is just nothing
and that transpose and nothing.
So now, I write S
as PD P transpose.
That's the spectral
decomposition
that I had before.
That's my eigenvalue
decomposition,
which means that now,
if I look at S prime,
it's P transpose times
PD P transpose P.
But now, P transpose
P is the identity,
P transpose P is the identity.
So this is actually
just equal to D.
And again, you can
check that this also
works if you have to center
all those guys as you go.
But if you think about
it, this is the same thing
as saying that I just
replaced Xi by Xi minus X bar.
And then it's true that Y bar
is also P times Xi minus X bar.
So now, we have that D is
the empirical covariance
matrix of those guys--
the Yi's, which are
P transpose Xi's.
And so in particular,
what it means
is that if I look at the
covariance of Yj Yk--
So that's the covariance
of the j-th coordinate of Y
and the k-th coordinate of Y.
I'm just not putting an index.
But maybe, let's say the
first one or something
like this-- any of
them, their IID.
Then what is this covariance?
It's actually 0 if j
is different from k.
And the covariance
between Yj and Yj,
which is just the variance
of Yj, is equal to lambda j--
the j-th largest eigenvalue.
So the eigenvalues capture the
variance of my observations
in this new coordinate system.
And they're
completely orthogonal.
So what does that mean?
Well, again, remember,
if I chop off
the head of my Gaussian
in multi dimensions,
we said that what
we started from
was something that
looked like this.
And we said, well, there's one
direction that's important,
that's this guy, and one
important that's this guy.
When I applied a transformation
P transpose, what I'm doing
is that I'm realigning this
thing with the new axes.
Or in a way, rather
to be fair, I'm
not actually realigning
the ellipses with the axes.
I'm really realigning the
axes with the ellipses.
So really, what I'm doing is
I'm saying, after I apply P,
I'm just rotating this
coordinate system.
So now, it becomes this guy.
And now, my ellipses
actually completely align.
And what happens here is
that this coordinate is
independent of that coordinate.
And that's what we write
here, if they are Gaussian.
I didn't really tell this--
I'm only making statements
about covariances.
If they are Gaussians,
those implied statements
about independence.
So as I said, the
variance now, lambda 1,
is actually the variance
of P transpose Xi.
But if I look now at
the-- so this is a vector,
so I need to look at the
first coordinate of this guy.
So it turns out that
doing this is actually
the same thing as looking
at the variance of what?
Well, the first
column of P times Xi.
So that's the variance of--
I'm going to call it v1
transpose Xi, where P--
So the v1 vd in Rd
are eigenvectors.
And each vi is
associated to lambda i.
So that's what we saw when
we talked about this eigen
decomposition a
couple of slides back.
That's the one here.
So if I call the
columns of P v1 to vd,
this is what's happening.
So when I look at lambda
1, it's just the variance
of Xi inner product with v1.
And we made this picture
when we said, well,
let's say v1 is here
and then x1 is here.
And if vi has a unique
norm, then the inner product
between Xi and v1 is just
the length of this guy here.
So that's the variance of the
Xi says the length of Xi--
so this is 0-- that's the
length of Xi when I project it
onto the direction
that span by v1.
If v1 has length 2, this is
really just twice this length.
If vi has length 3,
it's three times this.
But it turns out that since
P satisfies P transpose
P is equal to the identity--
that's an orthogonal
matrix, that's right here--
then this is actually
saying the same thing
as vj transpose vj, which is
really the norm squared of vj,
is equal to 1.
And vj transpose vk is equal
to 0, if j is different from k.
The eigenvectors are
orthogonal to each other.
And they're actually
all of norm 1.
So now, I know that this
is indeed a direction.
And so when I look
at v1 transpose Xi,
I'm really measuring
exactly this length.
And what is this length?
It's the length of
the projection of Xi
onto this line.
That's the line
that's spanned by v1.
So if I had a very high
dimensional problem
and I started to look
at the direction v1--
let's say v1 now is
not a eigenvector,
it's any direction-- then
if I want to do this lower
dimensional projection, then
I have to understand how those
Xi's project onto the
line that's spanned by v1,
because this is all that I'm
going to be keeping at the end
of the day about Xi's.
So what we want is
to find the direction
where those Xi's,
those projections,
have a lot of variance.
And we know that the variance
of Xi on this direction
is actually exactly
given by lambda 1.
Sorry, that's the
empirical var--
yeah, I should
call variance hat.
That's the empirical variance.
Everything is in empirical here.
We're talking about the
empirical covariance matrix.
And so I also have that lambda
2 is the empirical variance
of when I project Xi onto
v2, which is the second one,
just for exactly this reason.
Any question?
So lambda j's are going
to be important for us.
Lambda j measure the
spread of the points
when I project them onto a
line which is a one dimensional
space.
And so I'm going to have-- let's
say I want to pick only one,
I'm going to have to find the
one dimensional space that
carries the most variance.
And I claim that
v1 is the one that
actually maximizes the spread.
So the claim-- so for
any direction, u in Rd--
and by direction, I really
just mean that the norm of u
is equal to 1.
I need to play fair--
I'm going to compare myself to
other things of lengths one,
so I need to play fair and
look at directions of length 1.
Now, if I'm interested
in the empirical variance
of X1 transpose--
sorry, u transpose X1 u
transpose Xn, then this thing
is maximized for
u equals v1, where
v1 is the eigenvector
associated to lambda 1
and lambda 1 is not
any eigenvalues,
it's the largest of all those.
So it's the largest eigenvalue.
So why is that true?
Well, there's also a claim
that for any direction u--
so that's 1 and 2--
the variance of u
transpose X-- now,
this is just a random variable,
and I'm looking about the true
variance--
this is maximized for u
equals, let's call it w1,
where w1 is the
eigenvector of sigma--
Now, I'm talking about
the true variance.
Whereas, here, I was talking
about the empirical variance.
So the true variance
is the eigenvectors
of the true sigma
associated to the largest
eigenvalue of sigma.
So I did not give it a name.
Here, that was lambda 1
for the empirical one.
For the true one,
you can give it
another name, mu 1 if you want.
But that's just the same thing.
All it's saying is like,
wherever I see empirical,
I can remove it.
So why is this claim true?
Well, let's look at the
second one, for example.
So what is the variance
of u transpose X?
So that's what I want to know.
So that's the expectation--
so let's assume that X is 0,
again, for same
reasons as before.
So what is the variance?
It's just the expectation
of the square?
I don't need to remove
the expectation.
And the expedition
of the square is just
the expectation
of u transpose X.
And then I'm going to write
the other one X transpose u.
And we know that this
is deterministic.
So I'm just going to take
that this is just u transpose
expectation of X X transpose u.
And what is this guy?
That's covariance sigma.
That's just what sigma is.
So the variance I can write
as u transpose sigma u.
We've made this
computation before.
And now what I want to claim
is that this thing is actually
less than the largest
eigenvalue, which I actually
called lambda 1 here.
I should probably not.
And the P is-- well, OK.
Let's just pretend
everything is not empirical.
So now, I'm going to write
sigma as P lambda 1 lambda n P
transpose.
That's just the
eigendecomposition,
where I admittedly reuse the
same notation as I did for S.
So I should really put
some primes everywhere,
so you know those are
things that are actually
different in practice.
So this is just that the
decomposition of sigma.
You seem confused, Helen.
You have a question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is-- when you
talked about the empirical data
and--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So OK--
so I can make
everything I'm saying,
I can talk about
either the variance
or the empirical variance.
And you can just add the
word empirical in front of it
whenever you want.
The same thing works.
But just for the sake of
removing the confusion,
let's just do it again
with S. So I'm just
going to do everything
with S. So I'm
going to assume that
X bar is equal to 0.
And here, I'm going to talk
about the empirical variance,
which is just 1/n
sum from i equal 1
to n of u transpose Xi squared.
So it's the same thing.
Everywhere you see
an expectation,
you just put in average.
And then I get 1/n
sum from i equal 1
to n of Xi Xi transpose.
And now, I'm going
to call this guy
S, because that's what it is.
So this is u transpose Su.
But just defined that I could
just replace the expectation
by averages everywhere,
you can tell
that the thing is going to work
for either one or the other.
So now, this thing
was actually-- so now,
I don't have any problem
with my notation.
This is actually the
decomposition of S.
That's just the
spectral decomposition
and it's to its eigenvalues.
And so now, what I have is that
when I look at u transpose Su,
this is actually equal
to P u transpose S Pu.
OK.
There's a transpose somewhere.
That's this guy.
And that's this guy.
Now-- sorry, that's
not P, that's
D. That's D, that's
this diagonal matrix.
Let's look at this thing.
And let's call P transpose
u, let's call it b.
So that's also a vector in Rd.
What is it?
It's just, I take a
unit vector, and then
I apply P transpose to it.
So that's basically what
happens to a unit vector
when I apply the same
change of basis that I did.
So I'm just changing my
orthogonal system the same way
I did for the other ones.
So what's happening
when I write this?
Well, now I have that u
transpose Su is b transpose Db.
But now, doing b transpose
Db when D is diagonal
and b is a vector is
a very simple thing.
I can expand it.
This is what?
This is just the
sum from j equal 1
to d of lambda j bj squared.
So that's just like matrix
vector multiplication.
And in particular, I know
that the largest of those guys
is lambda 1 and those
guys are all non-negative.
So this thing is actually
less than lambda 1 times
the sum from j equal 1 to
d of lambda j squared--
sorry, bj squared.
And this is just the
norm of b squared.
So if I want to prove what's on
the slide, all I need to check
is that b has norm, which is--
AUDIENCE: 1.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: At most, 1.
It's going to be at most 1.
Why?
Well, because b is really
just a change of basis for u.
And so if I take a vector,
I'm just changing its basis.
I'm certainly not
changing its length--
think of a rotation,
and I can also flip it,
but think of a rotation--
well, actually, for vector, it's
just going to be a rotation.
And so now, what
I have I just have
to check that the norm of
b squared is equal to what?
Well, it's equal to the norm
of P transpose u squared,
which is equal to u
transpose P P transpose u.
But P is orthogonal.
So this thing is actually
just the identity.
So that's just u
transpose u, which
is equal to the norm u
squared, which is equal to 1,
because I took u to have
norm 1 in the first place.
And so this-- you're right--
was actually of norm equal to 1.
I just needed to have
it less, but it's equal.
And so what I'm left with is
that this thing is actually
equal to lambda 1.
So I know that for
every u that I pick--
that has norm--
So I'm just reminding
you that u here
has norm squared equal to 1.
For every u that I
pick, this u transpose
Su is at mostly lambda 1.
So that's the u transpose
Su is at most lambda 1.
And we know that that's
the variance, that's
the empirical variance,
when I project my points
onto direction spanned by u.
So now, I have an
empirical variance,
which is at most lambda 1.
But I also know that if I take u
to be something very specific--
I mean, it was on
the previous board--
if I take u to be
equal to v1, then
this thing is actually
not an inequality,
this is an equality.
And the reason is, when I
actually take u to be v1,
all of these bj's are going to
be 0, except for the one that's
b1, which is itself equal to 1.
So I mean, we can
briefly check this.
But if I take v--
if u is equal to v1, what
I have is that u transpose
Su is equal to P transpose
v1 D P transpose v1.
But what is P transpose v1?
Well, remember P
transpose is just
the matrix that has
vectors v1 transpose here,
v2 transpose here, all the
way to vd transpose here.
And we know that when I take
vj transpose vk, I get 0,
if j is different from k.
And if j is equal to k, I get 1.
So P transpose v1
is equal to what?
Take v1 here and multiply it.
So the first coordinate
is going to be
v1 transpose v1, which is 1.
The second coordinate
is going to be
v2 transpose v1, which is 0.
And so I get 0's
all the way, right?
So that means that this
thing here is really
just the vector 1, 0, 0.
And here, this is just
the vector 1, 0, 0.
So when I multiply
it with this guy,
I am only picking up
the top left element
of D, which is lambda 1.
So for every one,
it's less lambda 1.
And for v1, it's
equal to lambda 1,
which means that it's
maximized for a equals v1.
And that's where
I said that this
is the fanciest non-convex
problem we know how to solve.
This was a problem that
was definitely non-convex.
We were maximizing a convex
function over a sphere.
But we know that v1,
which is something--
I mean, of course,
you still have
to believe me that
you can compute
the spectral decomposition
efficiently--
but essentially, if you've
taken linear algebra,
you know that you can
diagonalize a matrix.
And so you get that v1
is just the maximum.
So you can find your
maximum just by looking
at the spectral decomposition.
You don't have to
do any optimization
or anything like this.
So let's recap.
Where are we?
We've established
that if I start
with my empirical covariance
matrix, I can diagonalize it
and PD P transpose.
And then if I take the
eigenvector associated
to the largest eigenvalues-- so
if I permute the columns of P
and of D's in such
a way that they
are ordered from the
largest to the smallest when
I look at the diagonal
elements of D,
then if I pick the first
column of P, it's v1.
And v1 is the direction on
which, if I project my points,
they are going to carry the
most empirical variance.
Well, that's a good way.
If I told you,
pick one direction
along which if you were
to project your points
they would be as spread out
as possible, that's probably
the one you would pick.
And so that's exactly
what PCA is doing for us.
It says, OK, if you ask me
to take d prime equal to 1,
I will take v1.
I will just take the direction
that's spanned by v1.
And that's just when I come
back to this picture that
was here before, this is v1.
Of course, here, I
only have two of them.
So v2 has to be this
guy, or this guy,
or I mean or this thing.
I mean, I don't know
them up to sine.
But then if I have three--
think of like an olive
in three dimensions--
then maybe I have one
direction that's slightly more
elongated than the other one.
And so I'm going to
pick the second one.
And so the procedure is
to say, well, first, I'm
going to pick v1 the same way
I pick v1 in the first place.
So the first
direction I am taking
is the leading eigenvector.
And then I'm looking
for a direction.
Well, if I found
one-- the one I'm
going to want to find-- if you
say you can take d equal 2,
you're going to need
the basis for this guy.
So the second one has to be
orthogonal to the first one
you've already picked.
And so the second
one you pick is
the one that's just,
among all those that
are orthogonal to v1, maximized
the empirical variance
when you project onto it.
And it turns out that this
is actually exactly v2.
You don't have to
redo anything again.
You're eigendecomposition,
this is
just the second column
of P. Clearly, v2
is orthogonal to v1.
We just used it here.
This 0 here just says this
v2 is orthogonal to v1.
So they're like this.
And now, what I said--
what this slide
tells you extra--
is that v2 among all
those directions that are
orthogonal--
I mean, there's still
d minus 1 of them--
this is the one that
maximizes the, say,
residual empirical
variance-- the one that
was not explained by the first
direction that you picked.
And you can check that.
I mean, it's becoming a bit
more cumbersome to write down,
but you can check that.
If you're not convinced,
please raise your concern.
I mean, basically, one
way you view this to--
I mean, you're not really
dropping a coordinate,
because v1 is not a coordinate.
But let's assume actually for
simplicity that v1 was actually
equal to e1, that the direction
that carries the most variance
is the one that
just says, just look
at the first coordinate of X.
So if that was the case, then
clearly the orthogonal
directions are
the ones that comprise only
of the coordinates 2 to d.
So you could actually just
drop the first coordinate
and do the same thing on
a slightly shorter vector
of length d minus 1.
And then you would just look
at the largest eigenvector
of these guys, et
cetera, et cetera.
So in a way, that's
what's happening,
except that you rotate it
before you actually do this.
And that's exactly
what's happening.
So what we put together here
is essentially three things.
One was statistics.
Statistics says, if
you won't spread,
if you want information, you
should be looking at variance.
The second one was optimization.
Optimization said, well, if you
want to maximize spread, well,
you have to maximize variance
in a certain direction.
And that means maximizing
over the sphere of vectors
that have unique norm.
And that's an optimization
problem, which actually
turned out to be difficult.
But then the third thing that
we use to solve this problem
was linear algebra.
Linear algebra
said, well, it looks
like it's a difficult
optimization problem.
But it turns out that the
answer comes in almost--
I mean, it's not a closed form,
but those things are so used,
that it's almost a closed form--
says, just pick the
eigenvectors in order
of their associated eigenvalues
from largest to smallest.
And that's why principal
component analysis
has been so popular and has
gained huge amount of traction
since we had computers that were
allowed to compute eigenvalues
and eigenvectors for
matrices of gigantic sizes.
You can actually do that.
If I give you--
I don't know, this Google
video, for example,
is talking about words.
They want to do just the,
say, principal component
analysis of words.
So I give you all the
words in the dictionary.
And-- sorry, well,
you would have
to have a representation
for words,
so it's a little more
difficult. But how do I do this?
Let's say, for example,
pages of a book.
I want to understand
the pages of a book.
And I need to turn
it into a number.
And a page of a book is
basically the word count.
So I just count the number
of times "the" shows up,
the number of times "and"
shows up, number of times "dog"
shows up.
And so that gives me a vector.
It's in pretty high dimensions.
It's as many dimensions as there
are words in the dictionary.
And now, I want to visualize
how those pages get together--
are two pages very
similar or not.
And so what you would
do is essentially
just compute the largest
eigenvector of this matrix--
maybe the two largest-- and
then project this into a plane.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can we assume
the number of points
was far larger
than the dimension?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, but there's
many pages in the world.
There's probably more
pages in the world
than there's words
in the dictionary.
Yeah, so of course, if
you are in high dimensions
and you don't have
enough points,
it's going to be
clearly an issue.
If you have two points,
then the leading eigenvector
is going to be
just the line that
goes through those
two points, regardless
of what the dimension is.
And clearly, you're
not learning anything.
So you have to pick,
say, the k largest one.
If you go all the way, you're
just reordering your thing,
and you're not actually
gaining anything.
You start from d
and you go too d.
So at some point, this
procedure has to stop.
And let's say it stops at k.
Now, of course, you
should ask me a question,
which is, how do you choose k?
So that's, of course,
a natural question.
Probably the basic answer
is just pick k equals 3,
because you can
actually visualize it.
But what happens if I
take k is equal to 4?
If I take is equal
to 4, I'm not going
to be able to plot points
in four dimensions.
Well, I could, I
could add color,
or I could try to be a
little smart about it.
But it's actually
quite difficult.
And so what people tend to do,
if you have four dimensions,
they actually do a bunch
of two dimensional plots.
And that's what a computer--
a computer is not very good--
I mean, by default,
they don't spit out
three dimensional plots.
So let's say they want to plot
only two dimensional things.
So they're going to take the
first directions of, say, v1,
v2.
Let's say you have
three, but you
want to have only two
dimensional plots.
And then it's going to do
v1, v3; and then v2, v3.
So really, you take
all three of them,
but it's really just
showing you all choices
of pairs of those guys.
So if you were to
keep k is equal to 5,
you would have five,
choose two different plots.
So this is the actual
principal component algorithm,
how it's implemented.
And it's actually fairly simple.
I mean, it looks like
there's lots of steps.
But really, there's only
one that's important.
So the first one is the input.
I give you a bunch of points,
x1 to xn in d dimensions.
And step two is, well, compute
their empirical covariance
matrix S. The points themselves,
we don't really care.
We care about their
empirical covariance matrix.
So it's a d by d matrix.
Now, I'm going to feed that.
And that's where the actual
computation starts happening.
I'm going to feed that
to something that knows
how to diagonalize this matrix.
And you have to
trust me, if I want
to compute the k
largest eigenvalues
and my matrix is
d by d, it's going
to take me about k times
d squared operations.
So if I want only three,
it's 3 times d squared,
which is about--
d squared is the time for me
it takes to just even read
the matrix sigma.
So that's not too bad.
So what it's going to
spit out, of course,
is the diagonal matrix
D. And those are nice,
because they allow
me to tell me what
is the order in which I should
be taking the columns of P.
But what's really important
to me is v1 to vd,
because those are going to be
the ones I'm going to be using
to draw those plots.
And now, I'm going
to say, OK, I need
to actually choose some set k.
And I'm going to basically
truncate and look
only at the first
k columns of P.
Once I have those
columns, what I
want to do is to project
onto the linear span
of those columns.
And there's actually
a simple way
to do this, which is just take
this matrix P, which is really
the matrix of projection onto
the linear span of those k
columns.
And you just take Pk transpose.
And then you apply this to
every single one of your points.
Now Pk transpose, what is
the size of the matrix Pk?
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So
Pk is just this matrix.
I take the v1 and I stop at vk--
well--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
d by k, right?
Each of the column
is an eigenvector.
It's of dimension d.
I mean, that's a vector
in the original space.
So I have this d by k matrix.
So all it is is if I had my--
well, I'm going to talk in
a second about Pk transpose.
Pk transpose is
just this guy, where
I stop at the k-th vector.
So Pk transpose is k by d.
So now, when I take Yi,
which is Pk transpose Xi,
I end up with a point
which is in k dimensions.
I have only k coordinates.
So I took every single one
of my original points Xi,
which had d coordinates, and
I turned it into a point that
has only k coordinates.
Particularly, I could
have k is equal to 2.
This matrix is exactly
the one that projects.
If you think about
it for one second,
this is just the
matrix that says--
well, we actually did
that several times.
The matrix, so that
was this P transpose u
that showed up somewhere.
And so that's just
the matrix that
take your point X in,
say, three dimensions,
and then just project it
down to two dimensions.
And that's just-- it goes to the
closest point in the subspace.
Now, here, the floor is flat.
But we can pick any
subspace we want,
depending on what
the lambdas are.
So the lambdas were
important for us
to be able to identify
which columns to pick.
The fact that we assumed
that they were ordered
tells us that we can
pick the first ones.
If they were not
ordered, it would
be just a subset of the
columns, depending on what
the size of the eigenvalue is.
So each column is labeled.
And so then, of course, we
still have this question of,
how do I pick k?
So there's definitely the
matter of convenience.
Maybe 2 is convenient.
If it works for 2, you don't
have to go any farther.
But you might want
to say, well--
originally, I did
that to actually keep
as much information as possible.
I know that the
ultimate thing is
to keep as much information,
which would be to k
is equal d-- that's as much
information as you want.
But it's essentially the
same question about, well,
if I want to compress
a JPEG image,
how much information should
I keep so it's still visible?
And so there's some
rules for that.
But none of them is
actually really a science.
So it's really a
matter of what you
think is actually tolerable.
And we're just going to start
replacing this choice by maybe
another parameter.
So here, we're going to
basically replace k by alpha,
and so we just do stuff.
So the first one that
people do that is probably
the most popular one--
OK, the most popular
one is definitely
take k is equal to 2
or 3, because it's just
convenient to visualize.
The second most popular
one is the scree plot.
So the scree plot--
remember, I have my
values, lambda j's.
And I've chosen the
lambda j's to decrease.
So the indices are
chosen in such a way
that lambda is a
decreasing function.
So I have lambda 1, and
let's say it's this guy here.
And then I have lambda 2, and
And then I have lambda 3, and
let's say it's this guy here,
lambda 4, lambda 5, lambda 6.
And all I care about is
that this thing decreases.
The scree plot says
something like this--
if there's an inflection point,
meaning that you can sort of do
something like this and
then something like this,
you should stop at 3.
That's what the
scree plot tells you.
What it's saying in a way
is that the percentage
of the marginal
increment of explained
variance that you get
starts to decrease after you
pass this inflection point.
So let's see why I way this.
Well, here, what I
have-- so this ratio
that you see there is
actually the percentage
of explained variance.
So what it means is that, if I
look at lambda 1 plus lambda k,
and then I divide by lambda
1 plus lambda d, well,
what is this?
Well, this lambda
1 plus lambda d
is the total amount of variance
that I get in my points.
That's the trace of sigma.
So that's the variance
in the first direction
plus the variance in
the second direction
the third direction.
That's basically all the
variance that I have possible.
Now, this is the variance that
I kept in the first direction.
This is the variance that I
kept in the second direction,
all the way to the variance that
I kept in the k-th direction.
So I know that this number is
always less than or equal to 1.
And it's larger than 1.
And this is just
the proportion, say,
of variance explained
by v1 to vk,
or simply, the proportion of
explained variance by my PCA,
say.
So now, what this
thing is telling me,
its says, well, if
I look at this thing
and I start seeing this
inflection point, it's saying,
oh, here, you're gaining
a lot and lot of variance.
And then at some point,
you stop gaining a lot
in your proportion of
explained variance.
So this will
translate in something
where when I look at this ratio,
lambda 1 plus lambda k divided
by lambda 1 plus
lambda d, this would
translate into a function
that would look like this.
And what it's telling you,
it says, well, maybe you
should stop here, because
here every time you add one,
you don't get as much
as you did before.
You actually get like
smaller marginal returns.
So explained variance is
the numerator of this ratio.
And the total variance
is the denominator.
Those are pretty
straightforward terms
that you would want
to use for this.
So if your goal is to
do data visualization--
so why would you
take k larger than 2?
Let's say, if you
take k larger than 6,
you can start to
imagine that you're
going to have six, choose two,
which starts to be annoying.
And if you have k
is equal to 10--
because you could start
in dimension 50,000--
and then k equal to
10 would be the place
where you have this thing
that's a lot of plots
that you would have to show.
So it's not always for
data visualization.
Once I've actually
done this, I've
actually effectively reduced
the dimension of my problem.
And what I could do
with what I have is
do a regression on those guys.
The v1-- so I
forgot to tell you--
why is that called principal
component analysis?
Well, the vj's that
I keep, v1 to vk
are called principal components.
And they effectively act
as the summary of my Xi's.
When I mentioned
image compression,
I started with a point
Xi that was d numbers--
let's say 50,000 numbers.
And now, I'm saying,
actually, you
can throw out those
50,000 numbers.
If you actually know only
the k numbers that you need--
the 6 numbers that you need--
you're going to
have something that
was pretty close to getting
what information you had.
So in a way, there is
some form of compression
that's going on here.
And what you can do is that
those principal components,
you can actually use
now for regression.
If I want to regress
Y onto X that's
very high dimensional,
before I do this,
if I don't have enough points,
maybe what I can actually do
is to do principal
component analysis
throughout my
exercise, replace them
by those compressed versions,
and do linear aggression
on those guys.
And that's called principal
component regression,
not surprisingly.
And that's something
that's pretty popular.
And you can do with k is
equal to 10, for example.
So for data visualization, I did
not find a Thanksgiving themed
picture.
But I found one that
has turkey in it.
Get it?
So this is actually a
gene data set that was--
so when you see
something like this,
you can imagine that someone
has been preprocessing
the hell out of this thing.
This is not like, oh, I
collect data on 23andMe
and I'm just going
to run PCA on this.
It just doesn't
happen like that.
And so what happened is that--
so let's assume that this was
a bunch of preprocessed data,
which are gene expression
levels--
so 500,000 genes
among 1,400 Europeans.
So here, I actually
have less observations
than I have samples.
And that's when you use
principal component regression
most of the time, so
it doesn't stop you.
And then what you do is you say,
OK, have those 500,000 genes
among--
so here, that means that
there's 1,400 points here.
And I actually take
those 500,000 directions.
So each person has a vector
of, say, 500,000 genes
that are attached to them.
And I project them onto
two dimensions, which
should be extremely lossy.
I lose a lot of information.
And indeed, I do, because
I'm one of these guys.
And I'm pretty sure I'm very
different from this guy,
even though probably from
an American perspective,
we're all the same.
But I think we have like
slightly different genomes.
And so the thing is
now we have this--
so you see there's lots of
Swiss that participate in this.
But actually, those two
principal components
recover sort of
the map of Europe.
I mean, OK, again, this is
actually maybe fine-grained
for you guys.
But right here, there's
Portugal and Spain,
which are those colors.
So here is color-coded.
And here is Turkey, of
course, which we know
has very different genomes.
So Turks are very
at the boundary.
So you can see all the greens.
They stay very far apart
from everything else.
And then the rest
here is pretty mixed.
But it sort of recovers--
if you look at the colors,
it sort of recovers that.
So in a way, those two
principal components
are just the geographic feature.
So if you insist to compress
all the genomic information
of these people into two
numbers, what you're actually
going to get is
longitude and latitude,
which is somewhat
surprising, but not
so much if you think that's
it's been preprocessed.
So what do you do
beyond practice?
Well, you could try to
actually study those things.
If you think about
it for a second,
we did not do any statistics.
I talked to you about
IID observations,
but we never used the fact
that they were independent.
The way we typically
use independence
is to have central
limit theorem, maybe.
I mentioned the fact that
the covariances of the word
Gaussian would actually give me
something which is independent.
We didn't care.
This was a data analysis, data
mining process that we did.
I give you points, and you just
put them through the crank.
There was an algorithm
in six steps.
And you just put it through
and that's what you got.
Now, of course, there's some
work which studies says, OK,
if my data is actually generated
from some process-- maybe,
my points are multivariate
Gaussian with some structure
on the covariance--
how well am I recovering
the covariance structure?
And that's where
statistics kicks in.
And that's where we stop.
So this is actually a bit
more difficult to study.
But in a way, it's not
entirely satisfactory,
because we could work
for a couple of boards
and I would just basically
sort of reverse engineer this
and find some models under which
it's a good idea to do that.
And what are those models?
Well, those are the models
that sort of give you
sort of prominent directions
that you want to find.
And it will say, yes, if you
have enough observations,
you will find those
directions along which
your data is elongated.
So that's essentially
what you want to do.
So that's exactly what
this thing is telling you.
So where does the
statistics lie from?
Well, everything, remember--
so actually that's
where Alana was confused--
the idea was to say, well,
if I have a true
covariance matrix sigma
and I never really
have access to it,
I'm just running PCA on the
empirical covariance matrix,
how do those results relate?
And this is something
that you can study.
So for example, if
n goes to infinity
and the number of points,
your dimension, is fixed,
then S goes to sigma
in any sense you want.
Maybe each entry is going
to each entry of sigma,
for example.
So S is a good estimator.
We know that the
empirical covariance
is a consistent as the mater.
And if d is fixed, this
is actually not an issue.
So in particular, if you run
PCA on the sample covariance
matrix, you look
at, say, v1, then
v1 is going to converge to the
largest eigenvector of sigma
as n goes to infinity,
but for d fixed.
And that's a story that
we know since the '60s.
More recently, people have
started challenging this.
Because what's happening
when you fix the dimension
and let the sample
size go to infinity,
you're certainly not
allowing for this.
It's certainly not explaining
to you anything about the fact
when d is equal to 500,000
and n is equal to 1,400.
Because when d is fixed
and n goes to infinity,
in particular, n is
much larger than d,
which is not the case here.
And so when n is much larger
than d, things go well.
But if d is less than n,
it's not clear what happens.
And particularly, if d is of the
order of n, what's happening?
So there's an entire theory
in mathematics that's called
random matrix theory that
studies the behavior of exactly
this question-- what is the
behavior of the spectrum--
the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors--
of a matrix in which I put
random numbers and I let--
so the matrix I'm interested
in here is the matrix of X's.
When I stack all my
X's next to each other,
so that's a matrix of size,
say, d by n, so each column
is of size d, it's one person.
And so I put them.
And when I let the
matrix go to infinity,
I let both d and n to infinity.
But I want the aspect ratio,
d/n, to go to some constant.
That's what they do.
And what's nice is that in the
end, you have this constant--
let's call it gamma--
that shows up in
all the asymptotics.
And then you can
replace it by d/n.
And you know that you still have
a handle of both the dimension
and the sample size.
Whereas, usually the dimension
goes away, as you let n
go to infinity without having
dimension going to infinity.
And so now, when
this happens, as soon
as d/n goes to a
constant, you can
show that essentially there's
an angle between the largest
eigenvector of sigma and the
largest eigenvector of S, as n
and d go to infinity.
There is always an
angle-- you can actually
write it explicitly.
And it's an angle that
depends on this ratio, gamma--
the asymptotic ratio of d/n.
And so there's been a lot of
understanding how to correct,
how to pay attention to this.
This creates some biases that
were sort of overlooked before.
In particular, when
I do this, this
is not the proportion
of explained variance,
when n and d are similar.
This is an estimated
number computed from S.
This is computed from S. All
these guys are computed from S.
So those are
actually not exactly
where you want them to be.
And there's some nice work that
allows you to recalibrate what
this ratio should be, how
this ratio should be computed,
so it's a better
representative of what
the proportion of explained
variance actually is.
So then, of course,
there's the question
of-- so that's when d/n
goes to some constant.
So the best case--
so that was '60s--
d is fixed and it's
much larger than d.
And then random matrix theory
tells you, well, d and n
are sort of the same
order of magnitude.
When they go to infinity, the
ratio goes to some constant.
Think of it as being order 1.
To be fair, if d is 100 times
larger than n, it still works.
And it depends on
what you think what
the infinity is at this point.
But I think the random matrix
theory results are very useful.
But then even in
this case, I told you
that the leading
eigenvector of S
is actually an angle of the
leading eigenvector of--
So what's happening is that--
so let's say that d/n
goes to some gamma.
And what I claim is
that, if you look at--
so that's v1, that's the v1 of
S. And then there's the v1 of--
so this should be of size 1.
So that's the v1 of sigma.
Then those things are going
to have an angle, which
is some function of gamma.
It's complicated, but
there's a function of gamma
that you can see there.
And there's some models.
When gamma goes
to infinity, which
means that d is now
much larger than n,
this angle is 90
degrees, which means
that you're getting nothing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If d is not
on your lower plane,
so like gamma is 0,
is there still angle?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: No,
but that's consistent--
the fact that it's
consistent when--
so the angle is a function--
AUDIENCE: d is not a
constant [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
d is not a constant?
So if d is little of n?
Then gamma goes to 0 and
f of gamma goes to 0.
So f of gamma is
a function that--
so for example, if f of gamma--
this is the sine of the
angle, for example--
then it's a function that starts
at 0, and that goes like this.
But as soon as gamma is
positive, it goes away from 0.
So now when gamma
goes to infinity,
then this thing goes
to a right angle, which
means I'm getting just junk.
So this is not my
leading eigenvector.
So how do you do this?
Well, just like
everywhere in statistics,
you have to just make
more assumptions.
You have to assume
that you're not
looking for the leading
eigenvector or the direction
that carries the most variance.
But you're looking, maybe,
for a special direction.
And that's what
sparse PCA is doing.
Sparse PCA is saying, I'm not
looking for any direction new
that carries the most variance.
I'm only looking for a
direction new that is sparse.
Think of it, for example, as
having 10 non-zero coordinates.
So that's a lot of
directions still to look for.
But once you do this,
then you actually
have not only--
there's a few things
that actually you
get from doing this.
The first one is you
actually essentially replace
d by k, which means
that n now just--
I'm sorry, let's say S
non-zero coefficients.
You replace d by S,
which means that n only
has to be much larger than S
for this thing to actually work.
Now, of course, you've
set your goal weaker.
Your goal is not to
find any direction, only
a sparse direction.
But there's something
very valuable
about sparse directions,
is that they actually
are interpretable.
When I found the v--
let's say that the v
that I found before
was 0.2, and then 0.9, and
then 1.1 minus 3, et cetera.
So that was the coordinates
of my leading eigenvector
in the original
coordinate system.
What does it mean?
Well, it means that if
I see a large number,
that means that this
v is very close--
so that's my original
coordinate system.
Let's call it e1 and e2.
So that's just 1,
0; and then 0, 1.
Then clearly, from
the coordinates of v,
I can tell if my v is like
this, or it's like this,
or it's like this.
Well, I mean, they should
all be of the same size.
So I can tell if
it's here or here
or here, depending
on-- like here,
that means I'm going
to see something
where the Y-coordinate it much
larger than the X-coordinate.
Here, I'm going to see something
where the X-coordinate is much
larger than the Y-coordinate.
And here, I'm going
to see something
where the X-coordinate
is about the same size
of the Y-coordinate.
So when things
starts to be bigger,
you're going to have
to make choices.
What does it mean to be bigger--
when d is 100,000,
I mean, the sum
of the squares of those
guys have to be equal to 1.
So they're all
very small numbers.
And so it's hard for you to
tell which one is a big number
and which ones is
a small number.
Why would you want to know this?
Because it's
actually telling you
that if v is very close to
e1, then that means that e1--
in the case of the
gene example, that
would mean that e1 is the
gene that's very important.
Maybe there's actually
just two genes
that explain those two things.
And those are the genes
that have been picked up.
There's two genes that I
encode geographic location,
and that's it.
And so it's very
important for you
to be able to
interpret what v means.
Where it has large
values, it means
that maybe it has large
values for e1, e2, and e3.
And it means that it's a
combination of e1, e2, and e3.
And now, you can
interpret, because you have
only three variables to find.
And so sparse PCA
builds that in.
Sparse PCA says,
listen, I'm going
to want to have at most
10 non-zero coefficients.
And the rest, I want to be 0.
I want to be able to be a
combination of at most 10
of my original variables.
And now, I can do
interpretation.
So the problem
with sparse PCA is
that it becomes very
difficult numerically
to solve this problem.
I can write it.
So the problem is simply
maximize the variance u
transpose, say, Su
subject to-- well,
I wanted to have u2 equal to 1.
So that's the original PCA.
But now, I also
want that the sum
of the indicators of the
uj that are not equal to 0
is at most, say, 10.
This constraint is
very non-convex.
So I can relax it
to a convex one
like we did for
linear aggression.
But now, I've totally
messed up with the fact
that I could use linear
algebra to solve this problem.
And so now, you have to go
through much more complicated
optimization techniques,
which are called
semidefinite
programs, which do not
scale well in high dimensions.
And so you have to do
a bunch of tricks--
numerical tricks.
But there are some packages
that implements some heuristics
or some other things--
iterative
thresholding, all sorts
of various numerical
tricks that you can do.
But the problem they are trying
to solve is exactly this.
Among all directions that
I have norm 1, of course,
because it's the direction
that have at most, say,
10 non-zero coordinates, I want
to find the one that maximizes
the empirical variance.
Actually, let me let
me just so you this.
I wanted to show
you an output of PCA
where people are actually
trying to do directly--
maybe-- there you go.
So right here, you
see this is SPSS.
That's a statistical software.
And this is an output
that was preprocessed
by a professional--
not preprocessed,
post-processed.
So that's something
where they read PCA.
So what is the data?
This is raw data
about you ask doctors
what they think of the
behavior of a particular sales
representative for
pharmaceutical companies.
So pharmaceutical
companies are trying
to improve their sales force.
And they're asking
doctors how would they
rate-- what do they value
about their interaction
with a sales representative.
So basically, there's
a bunch of questions.
One offers credible point
of view on something trends,
provides valuable
networking opportunities.
This is one question.
Rate this on a
scale from 1 to 5.
That was the question.
And they had a bunch
of questions like this.
And then they asked 1,000
doctors to make those ratings.
And what they want--
so each doctor now
is a vector of ratings.
And they want to know if there's
different groups of doctors,
what do doctors respond to.
If there's different
groups, then
maybe they know that they
can actually address them
separately, et cetera.
And so to do that, of course,
there's lots of questions.
And so what you want is
to just first project
into lower dimensions,
so you can actually
visualize what's going on.
And this is what
was done for this.
So these are the three
first principal component
that came out.
And even though we ordered
the values of the lambdas,
there's no reason why the
entries of v should be ordered.
And if you look at
the values of v here,
they look like they're
pretty much ordered.
It starts at 0.784, and then
you're at 0.3 around here.
There's something that goes up
again, and then you go down.
Actually, it's marked in red
every time it goes up again.
And so now, what they
did is they said,
OK, I need to
interpret those guys.
I need to tell you what this is.
If you tell me, we found
the principal component
that really discriminates
the doctors in two groups,
the drug company is
going to come back to you
and say, OK, what is
this characteristic?
And you say, oh, it's
actually a linear combination
of 40 characteristics.
And they say, well, we
don't need you to do that.
I mean, it cannot be a linear
combination of anything you
didn't ask.
And so for that,
first of all, there's
a post-processing of PCA, which
says, OK, once I actually,
say, found three
principal components,
that means that I found the
dimension three space on which
I want to project my points.
In this base, I can pick
any direction I want.
So the first thing
is that you do
some sort of local arrangements,
so that those things
look like they are increasing
and then decreasing.
So you just change, you
rotate your coordinate system
in this three dimensional space
that you've actually isolated.
And so once you do
this, the reason
to do that is that
it sort of makes
them big, sharp differences
between large and small values
of the coordinates
of the thing you had.
And why do you want this?
Because now, you
can say, well, I'm
going to start looking at the
ones that have large values.
And what do they say?
They say in-depth knowledge,
in-depth knowledge,
knowledge about.
This thing is clearly
something that
actually characterizes
the knowledge of my sales
representative.
And so that's something that
doctors are sensitive to.
That's something that
really discriminates
the doctors in a way.
There's lots of variance
along those things,
or at least a lot of variance--
I mean, doctors are separate
in terms of their experience
with respect to this.
And so what they
did is said, OK,
all these guys, some of
those they have large values,
but I don't know how
to interpret them.
And so I'm just going
to put the first block,
and I'm going to call
it medical knowledge,
because all those things are
knowledge about medical stuff.
Then here, I didn't know
how to interpret those guys.
But those guys, there's a big
clump of large coordinates,
and they're about respectful
of my time, listens, friendly
but courteous.
This is all about the
quality of interaction.
So this block was actually
called quality of interaction.
And then there
was a third block,
which you can tell starts to
be spreading a little thin.
There's just much less of them.
But this thing was
actually called
fair and critical opinion.
And so now, you have three
discriminating directions.
And you can actually
give them a name.
Wouldn't it be beautiful if
all the numbers in the gray box
came non-zero and
all the other numbers
came zero-- there
was no ad hoc choice.
I mean, this is probably
an afternoon of work
to like scratch out
all these numbers
and put all these
color codes, et cetera.
Whereas, you could just have
something that tells you,
OK, here are the non-zeros.
If you can actually make a story
around why this group of thing
actually makes sense, such
as it is medical knowledge,
then good for you.
Otherwise, you could
just say, I can't.
And that's what sparse
PCA does for you.
Sparse PCA outputs something
where all those numbers would
be zero.
And there would be exactly,
say, 10 non-zero coordinates.
And you can turn
this knob off 10.
You can make it 9.
Depending on what
your major is, maybe
you can actually go
on with 20 of them
and have the ability to
tell the story about 20
different variables and how
they fit in the same group.
And depending on
how you feel, it's
easy to rerun the PCA
depending on the value
that you want here.
And so you could actually
just come up with the one
you prefer.
And so that's the
sparse PCA thing
which I'm trying to promote.
I mean, this is not
super well-spread.
It's a fairly new idea,
maybe at most 10 years old.
And it's not
completely well-spread
in statistical packages.
But that's clearly
what people are
trying to emulate currently.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what
exactly does it
mean that the doctors
have a lot of variance
in medical knowledge,
quality of interaction,
and fair and critical opinion?
Like, it was saying that
these are like the main things
that doctors vary on,
some doctors care.
Like we could sort of
characterize a doctor by, oh,
he cares this much about
medical knowledge, this much
about the quality
of interaction,
and this much about
critical opinion.
And that says most of the story
about what this doctor wants
from a drug representative?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Not really.
I mean, OK, let's say
you pick only one.
So that means that you
would take all your doctors,
and you would have
one direction, which
is quality of interaction.
And there would be just
spread out points here.
So there are two
things that can happen.
The first one is that
there's a clump here,
and then there's a clump here.
That still represents
a lot of variance.
And if this happens,
you probably
want to go back in
your data and see
were these people visited
by a different group
than these people,
or maybe these people
have a different specialty.
I mean, you have to
look back at your data
and try to understand
why you would have
different groups of people.
And if it's like completely
evenly spread out,
then all it's saying
is that, if you
want to have a uniform
quality of interaction,
you need to take
measures on this.
You need to have this to
not be discrimination.
But I think really when it's
becoming interesting it's not
when it's complete spread out.
It's when there's
a big group here.
And then there's
almost no one here,
and then there's
a big group here.
And then maybe there's
something you can do.
And so those two things actually
give you a lot of variance.
So actually, maybe
I'll talk about this.
Here, this is sort of a mixture.
You have a mixture of
two different populations
of doctors.
And it turns out that
principal component analysis--
so a mixture is when you
have different populations--
think of like two
Gaussians that are just
centered at two
different points,
and maybe they're
in high dimensions.
And those are
clusters of people,
and you want to be able to
differentiate those guys.
If you're in very
high dimensions,
it's going to be very
difficult. But one
of the first processing tools
that people do is to do PCA.
Because if you have one big
group here and one big group
here, it means that
there's a lot of variance
along the direction that
goes through the centers
of those groups.
And that's essentially
what happened here.
You could think of this as being
two blobs in high dimensions.
But you're really
just projecting them
into one dimension.
And this dimension, hopefully,
goes through the center.
And so as preprocessing--
so I'm going to stop here.
But PCA is not just made
for dimension reduction.
It's used for
mixtures, for example.
It's also used when you
have graphical data.
What is the idea of PCA?
It just says, if you have a
matrix that seems to have low
rank-- meaning that there's a
lot of those lambda i's that
are very small--
and then I see that
plus noise, then
it's a good idea to
do PCA on this thing.
And in particular, people
use that in networks a lot.
So you take the adjacency
matrix of a graph--
well, you sort of preprocess it
a little bit, so it looks nice.
And then if you have, for
example, two communities
in there, it should
look like something that
is low rank plus some noise.
And low rank means that there's
just very few non-zero--
well, low rank means this.
Low rank means that if
you do the scree plot,
you will see
something like this,
which means that if you throw
out all the smaller ones,
it should not really matter
in the overall structure.
And so you can use all--
these techniques are used
everywhere these days, not
just in PCA.
So we call it PCA
as statisticians.
But people call it the
spectral methods or SVD.
So everyone--